le bloc québécois a présenté son cadre
financier le bloc ne prévoit pas de
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire au cours
des quatre prochaines années
déficits successifs de 17 12 12 et près
de 15 milliards de dollars en 2000 23 24
le bloc prévoit 15 milliards 900
millions de dollars de nouveaux revenus
en 2023 24,6 milliards dans la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux
la vente du pipeline trans mountain
rapporterait dans quatre ans un milliard
800 millions de dollars
la perception de la tps et la taxe
netflix sur les géants du web
elle rapporterait 1 milliard 400
millions et la péréquation verte
rapporterait 1 milliard 800 millions
le bloc prévoit plus de 19 milliards de
dollars de nouvelles dépenses les
transferts aux provinces ont augmenté de
7 milliards 300 millions iraient
bonification aussi quand même important
de la sécurité de la vieillesse 7
milliards 500 millions
il ya de l'argent aussi prévues pour les
rénovations écoénergétiques et la
culture gabriel sainte-marie candidat
dans joliette pour le bloc québécois
pour soi monsieur sainte marie bonsoir
monsieur fillion en regardant votre
cadre financier aujourd'hui j'avais
l'impression qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
revenus qui s'appuyait sur le concours
d'entente internationale quand vous
parlez de la fin d'utilisation légale
des paradis fiscaux de la lutte à
l'évasion fiscale à l'international même
de la taxe netflix non dans un certain
sens c'est ce que vos projections de
revenus reposent essentiellement sur des
sources vraiment incertaine mais si on
prend par exemple l'utilisation légale
mais il moral des paradis fiscaux
ottawa ont le pouvoir de demander à ces
entreprises de ne plus délocaliser leurs
leur réactivité qui sont réalisées au
canada mais qui sont virtuellement
délocaliser dans ces pays
l'utilisation faite par les entreprises
ça passe par un règlement de la loi de
l'impôt
moi c'est pas dans les conventions
fiscales où on le retrouve et pendant le
dernier mandat j'ai essayé de ma demande
au gouvernement permet pas d'abolir
cette échappatoire qui présentement les
gars mais je regarde en 2009 1,3 1,4 à
peu près 10 milliards que vous voulez
aller chercher simplement dans la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux et l'évasion
fiscale oui quand même tout mandat de
dire on va aller chercher dit
il ya les gouvernements essaient d'aller
chercher depuis des années qu'ils nous
promettent d'aller chercher plus
d'argent dans les paradis fiscaux
oui et je pense est important de réussir
à le faire puis à port à port abdiqué ça
se divise en deux la partie de
l'utilisation légale et aso vient
s'ajouter la lutte à l'évasion qui est
illégal qu ici dans l'est mais les
chiffres annoncés
ça vise les entreprises qui utilisent
80% de l'évasion fiscale ce sont les
entreprises on le met les revenus de
façon progressive sur trois ans et on se
base sur les chiffres du directeur
parlementaire du budget dans le cas de
la taxe
netflix beaucoup de gens doute la
faisabilité des économistes de sa de
taxer à 3% les revenus des géants du web
parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment toutes les
informations sur les revenus des géants
du web en sol canadien
comment on peut faire ça ben justement à
mon avis c'est le rôle du gouvernement
d'aller chercher ces informations là si
l'état peut pas savoir ce que l'activité
économique qui se passe chez lui même
on a un sérieux problème nous ce qu'on
propose c'est d'emboîter le pas à ce
qu'ils aient commencé à se faire en
france puis d'autres pays aussi ont
embarqué dans le bal donc percevoir la
tps qui est l'essentiel des revenus mais
aussi aller chercher à 3 % sur le
chiffre d'affaires alors là tu sais à
peu près 1 8 milliard 300 millions et un
milliard 400 millions simplement pour
percevoir le texte taxé tps c'est
vraiment dans vos dans vos revenus dans
vos revenus aussi vous vendez prince
20ten oui tout à fait est-ce qu'on radie
notre investissement notre indice pente
comment là on l'a présenté ici dans le
budget pour la première les uns le cadre
financier pour la première année on le
vend sa juste valeur marchande 3,6
milliards c'est 4.5 oui c'est le
directeur parlementaire du budget avait
rappelé que c'était 900 millions d'euros
donc on le vend sa juste valeur et on
met on l'agrandît repos donc le 9
milliards qui avait été annoncé pour le
construire le nouveau pari plane sur le
à côté d'une éventuelle inactuel bien on
le fait pas donc on l'amorti sur cinq
ans 1,1
milliards par année donc on vend le
projet où on va le pipeline actuelle et
on ne fait pas l'ex pas exactement c'est
ce que vous proposez est ce qu'un parti
qui aspire à diriger tout le canada ce
qui provoqua est ce qu'un parti qui
aspire à diriger le canada peut se
permettre de ne pas croire au pétrole
investir dans le pétrole crée des
pipelines supplémentaire est un premier
ministre peut devenir premier ministre
du canada
s'il ne croit pas à cette industrie bras
c'est certain qu'il va avoir des grands
débats sujet-là en chambre ça c'est
certain on l'entend chaque jour
l'importance de la filière pétrolière
pour l'économie canadienne
toutefois l'oeil aux urgences
climatiques et puis on peut pas se
permettre de faire comme on le fait dans
le dernier mandat continuer à voir une
croissance de ce secteur
on parle de 24% d'extraction
supplémentaires à travers les quatre
dernières années on peut pas on peut pas
accepter ça donc il faut il faut viser
la décroissance de secteurs l'eau à
vitesse grand v pour réaliser notre
contribution à l'urgence climatique
péréquation verte c'est votre concept
équation ouvertes qui se trouve à
apprendre la taxe carbone en fait
l'argent de la tarification carbone pour
redistribuer ça en les bonnes province a
exactement les bonnes province qui
consomment du pétrole de l'alberta mais
qui n'en produisent pas on calcule les
gs par habitant par province
et puis le ici après ça c'est une course
à l'innovation entre les provinces plus
une province ou un écart élevé entre la
moyenne canadienne et les émissions par
habitant que dans sa province plus elle
va payer la taxe carbone et lorsqu'on
est sous la moyenne
eh bien l'on reçoit de façon
proportionnelle à l'écart à la moyenne a
encore une fois donc ça amène une course
à l'innovation je convaincs le province
mais est ce que ça ne vient pas jouer
contre le principe de la taxe carbone
c'est à dire la taxe carbone on impose
mais en retour on investit dans des
technologies durables dans la province
où on retourne d'échec d'impôts dans la
province alors que là c'est une vraie un
transfert réel de l'alberta par exemple
vers le québec est exactement puis
toutefois il faut ajouter ont détesté
encore plus la taxe carbone vous pensez
pas toutefois il faut ajouter que pour
les provinces qui
avait de la péréquation comme les
maritimes et le québec bella pour chaque
dollar perçu au niveau de cette
péréquation verte là on vient soustraire
90 ou de la péréquation du paiement de
la péréquation standard mais je suis
d'accord avec vous on fait payer les
pollueurs et c'est le plan qu'on propose
si vous étiez le gouvernement du canada
vous seriez très généreux avec les aînés
les pensions de vieillesse notamment 7
milliards et demi pour augmenter la
sécurité de la vieillesse c'est plus
gros chiffre dans votre cadre financier
pourquoi le plus gros chiffre c'est pour
les personnes de 65 ans et plus au cours
des dernières années une plus en mesure
pour les familles pour la classe moyenne
mais un peu tout le monde et sont le vus
on le voit sur le terrain
les oubliés ont été nos élections qui
ont pris soin de nous puis si on est où
on est aujourd'hui c'est grâce à leur
apport donc là c'est à mon avis ou à
notre avis c'est de rétablir un peu plus
d'équité on le voit les années nous le
dise le coût de la vie augmente souvent
les les loyers dans les résidences a
augment et leurs revenus ne suivent pas
donc on a ciblé la sécurité de la
vieillesse
et puis nous on propose de ramener ça à
15 % du salaire médian qu'on observe
donc ça fait un peu plus de 100 dollars
par mois c'est une mesure qui coûte cher
mais le besoin est là
gabriel péri merci beaucoup merci à vous